hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you to see all your
tweaks going have you almost made it to
Friday I am in New York City if I can
wake up in a city that blows me just for
being there and where my [ __ ]
sweatpants while eating Tad's steaks
there's so many people not make it into
New York but they play that [ __ ] song
and everybody thinks they're making it
right these [ __ ] homeless people are
taking public shits on the subway grates
and they drop down on Wall Street people
now that was the 90s it all gradually
went away it all went away and now
there's like bicycles and chairs in the
streets this is all [ __ ] I might be
talking about tonight I am in New York
for my final press stop and then I am
done hyping the for the most part I'm
done open the second season of Ephesus
family I told you was out there take it
or leave it either want to watch you too
you don't I'm going to be doing a
Stephen Colbert tonight however it will
not air until tomorrow so one of the
hardest things about doing his show
tonight is aside from the fact I believe
he tapes at the Ed Sullivan Theater
which is where I used to stand up when I
did Letterman which is where the Beatles
you know did their thing which is where
Jackie Mason allegedly flipped off
somebody you know when he still
maintains he didn't back on The Ed
Sullivan Show okay
new who's kidding hope you want to go
far enough back I'm sure there was some
Native Americans just chilling out there
eating a [ __ ] rabbit thinking look at
this paradise it's like the entire strip
of Manhattan it all looks like Central
Park and the other Indian Native
American goes what the [ __ ] is Central
Park and then he points to a ship of
white people coming over the horizon
glad these [ __ ] people tell you about
the first [ __ ] Quakers with a quake
what's difference between Quakers and
those people with the buckles on their
hats at first stopped off at Plymouth
Rock if that ever happened on the Nina
the Pinta and the Santa Maria Santa
Maria Nina the Pinta Center may sound
like they're from Spain right why were
they a bunch of white people from
England right in Spanish boats this is
like f1 let me get this straight this is
this is the team from India yet they
have a Mercedes engine um all right I'm
all over the map I'm all over the map I
need to get focused all right I am
pretty focused I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why old Billy no fun oh you
know it was Billy you know half a fun
you know cuz I was still celebrating my
birthday so I had a couple glasses of
wine you know sitting there like I was
sophisticated like I read you know like
I was a socialite like I was the kind of
person that you just invite to a party
because I'm an interesting person to
have there you know you ever seen that
like in France they still have
socialites they some I don't know how
they make a living but they're just
these people who don't really have jobs
and if you have a party it's not a party
unless you invite this person and
everybody's dying to get into the circle
that they stand in to discuss anything
from art to world politics to fashion
not saying that fashion isn't an art
form okay for all the [ __ ] dress
makers who listen to this I have a lot
of dress makers by the way they listen
to this podcast you know a lot of them
always have to stop and hit rewind
because some of their sequins hit the
floor and they couldn't quite make out
what I was saying
um what am I saying my voice is in the
same register as sequence it in the
floor I think I think I am I think
that's most roundabout way anybody has
ever called themselves you know a a bit
of a nancy boy oh you mean the guy with
these d sequent own voice all right what
am I saying here key I got it I have a
they have a major major announcement on
so many different levels here all right
I hope you're sitting down I'm pregnant
okay I was taking these hormones to try
and lose weight and I grew a womb
somehow I got abs but you know there's
always you know you can't have your cake
and eat it and somehow I got pregnant
you know you wouldn't think you know I
somehow felt jerking off sorry anyways
uh what I want to say here is Versys uh
Paul virzi I'm doing this bad
all right the all things comedy network
is going to be producing their first
hour-long stand-up special and the
person who would be picked to do it is
my good friend friend of the podcast one
of the Four Horsemen on the road that I
take out there Paul virzi is going to be
doing a special tickets are on sale now
all right and this actually the idea of
this was brought to us by his good
friend Saturday Night Live's own Pete
Davidson Pete Davidson Al and all things
comedies al Madrigal and myself are all
going to be involved with producing the
stand-up special and me and Pete will be
going on the night of Paul's shows he's
going to be doing two shows on August
13th one at 7:00 p.m. one at 9:30 p.m.
at the Tarrytown Music Hall in Tarrytown
New York one of my favorite theaters out
there and Paul's obviously going to be
closing doing is special and in the
beginning me and Pete are going to mess
around whatever do some stuff May
you laugh warm up the crowd for Paul and
Paul's going to absolutely kill it this
is the biggest thing that I've done in
my career I've never produced anything
like this we're putting a lot of money
out there Paul is a beast it would mean
the world to me and to Paul and to his
family back east all back east here if
you guys came down tickets are only 20
bucks I'll be hanging out meeting people
after the show whatever you want to do
I'll [ __ ] whatever you want me to do
just whatever I have to do to fill this
thing up so Paul virzi can do his
special here so we're gonna have the
ticket link and everything like that the
tickets are live whatever they you can
buy them right now you can pull over in
your car you can continue to drive and
run that risk and try to buy tickets
while you're driving August 13th it's a
Sunday night in August on the 13th 7:00
p.m. 9:30 p.m. the Tarrytown Music Hall
it's going to be huge night really
looking forward to it so oh and also you
know what else I forgot to bring up holy
[ __ ] the f is for family I tweeted about
it we finally we got some merch we got
t-shirts we got some for the ladies bump
for the men you know something for the
boys and girls we got everything down
there you know we got some Kevin shirts
Frank shirts efforts for family shirts
Vic shirts you know and just when you
think you have all the bases covered
people go what about this character why
don't you have his [ __ ] and I think cuz
they get their going mainstream at first
and then eventually everybody will have
some stuff all right anyway so let's get
down to what the [ __ ] went on this week
the big story yet that the taboo do do
do Conor McGregor and money Mayweather I
don't know his first name
the Floyd Floyd money money making get
money Mayweather are going to have a
boxing match in August pay-per-view what
do you guys think about this are you
going to take your hard-earned paper
that is backed by no gold
are you going to write a piece a number
on a piece of paper stick it in another
piece of paper and mail it to the
pay-per-view people to watch this fight
do you think eh this is [ __ ] amazing
or B this has got to be one of the
dumbest [ __ ] things I've ever heard
in my life um you know me I'm a [ __ ]
curmudgeon but I'm also wrong a lot God
knows that God knows I'm wrong I mean I
didn't know something the other day
would somebody correct me on I didn't
know about kryptonite people you know
and that's what I love about my fan base
on this podcast they're smart enough you
know when I make a major faux pas such
as that of not describing Superman's
planet blowing up and what kryptonite
really is you know I will always regret
that and I'll never be able to apologize
long enough a lot of people had to
apologize over the last couple of weeks
in my industry and and they put their
controversies behind them but I don't
think I'll ever outlive not knowing what
kryptonite was and I accept full
responsibility anyways this is like the
dumbest [ __ ] thing ever
okay Conor McGregor fights for a living
Mayweather fights for a living but
that's that's it so they're just gonna
box all right they're going to be
wearing the [ __ ] 16-ounce gloves
whatever the [ __ ] a boxer wears and this
is this is the stupidest [ __ ] thing
ever this is this is like watching
Durant go to the Warriors you know the
Warriors oh it's over it's [ __ ] over
it's over watching the Golden State
Warriors when the NBA championship this
year was basically watching like a bad
summertime movie it was big it was loud
and you knew how it was going to end and
it was it yeah it was [ __ ] boring
right by the way congratulations I
should at least do that okay means
[ __ ] the Warriors are amazing it's
actually bad that Durant joined them as
far as like their legacy because you
really had a team that you know has the
already had the potential to be like a
dynasty they came within a couple of
seconds so winning back-to-back without
Durant going there so congratulations to
the Warriors gradual ations to their
fans my condolences to any fan of
basketball that enjoys competition and
enjoy seven-game series congratulations
to people who want to save the
environment and want four people in a
[ __ ] car the pylon team that's the
basketball team for you because I just
look at it as a metaphor there wasn't a
lack of competition that was a thumbs-up
for the diamond lane let's get all the
stars in the same vehicle all right
McGregor verse that this would basically
be like if you took Jerry Rice in the
prime of his career Tom Brady in the
prime of his career and you like let's
figure out who's a better football
player but the only way you were going
to measure that it was how far they
could throw a football you aren't going
to do the 40-yard dash you weren't gonna
see if they could catch you know what I
mean I don't know it's just Mayweather
boxes they're gonna have a boxing match
no you know [ __ ] over this fight
would be if McGregor was allowed to use
you know everything else that he does
taking it to the ground that kicks the
[ __ ] choke choking him out all I mean
I don't I don't know [ __ ] about to fight
game and I know this is [ __ ] stupid
this is dumb
what do you have next to a [ __ ]
elephant first a [ __ ] cheetah they're
gonna have a footrace one of the
strongest animals ever one of the
fastest animals ever let's have a
competition between the two of them
based on nothing but speed dump truck
first Lamborghini both forms of
transportation yeah I'll tell you what's
going to be the only thing that's going
to be interesting is if mayweather can
actually knock him up he's a four year
old guy I know his hands uh you know he
I believe he has constant pain in them
I'm a huge fan of both of them and this
is nothing more than a [ __ ] money
grab this is a smash and [ __ ] grab
this is like what [ __ ] it's like with
Bobbi ray this is like I put this in the
same it's a better version of when Bobby
Riggs played Billie Jean King or [ __ ]
Muhammad Ali fought Lyle Alzado a Hulk
Hogan fought [ __ ] Rocky Balboa or
whatever the [ __ ] I mean this is it's
it's in that vein you know I think it's
really ironic that the circus just went
out of business and now they're having
this pay-per-view I bet the same people
who cashed out on the circus speaking of
elephants they got their money behind
this one this is not and what's going to
be funny is all the mouth breathers who
want to say boxing's a better form if
you know when mayweather beats [ __ ]
mcgregor by outpointing him or whatever
the [ __ ] he's going to do um everyone's
me see but Boston's better than MMA
expect he's not doing it this is like
[ __ ] having a breakdancer get guy a
battle a guy who does nothing but the
waltz and we're gonna have a waltzing
contest not to say that the breakdancer
couldn't figure out he just never enough
time so here's a deal I am I'm gonna say
this right now when I probably won't
because I'll probably get sucked in I'm
gonna do my best and I get into this to
get sucked into the hype of this [ __ ]
fight
all right I am going to I'm gonna wait
I'm just gonna I'm sitting it up okay
and I'm hoping I'm wrong and I hope
people say bill that was the greatest
[ __ ] fight I've ever seen in my life
it went to distances somehow against all
odds but Gregor beat Mayweather and then
I'll be like you know what then I'm
gonna I'll sit down and I'll [ __ ]
watch out dude I don't give a [ __ ]
that's like after you see our movie win
the Oscar you know you kind of know what
the movies about but you still haven't
seen it you can go back and watch it
right this is one thing I am really
excited about is that McGregor and
Mayweather are gonna make a bunch of
[ __ ] money good for them good for
them you know because those guys usually
end up with their brains all [ __ ] up
you know they might as well have some
money right it's so good for them so I'm
glad a bunch of people gonna watch that
and think that this is going to be you
know let's see what's better MMA or
[ __ ] boxing they already decided that
way back before Dana White even got into
this [ __ ] back when it was just remember
the early days when they didn't I didn't
know what the name of it was I remember
Patrice telling me dude you got to watch
this [ __ ] way back in the day when uh
you know that [ __ ] boxer came in
wearing one boxing glove he fought the
other guy he had one boxing glove on and
the other guy had more of a wrestling
background he just put the guy on his
back and now he's sitting there with one
hand and the other hands got a mitten on
it that's tied to his wrist and he can't
get it off it was a [ __ ] show so um I
don't know I don't know you never know
what the [ __ ] can happen you never know
what can happen but I will say this I
can't believe the [ __ ] put that together
Jesus Christ I can't imagine the amount
of Hoops you had to jump through now
that I'm getting into producing here and
I'm producing a special for Paul virzi
man look at me
I already feel a little more arrogant I
make myself some big fancy Hollywood
reading glasses those giant ones hey by
the way what is going on with the world
this [ __ ] guy went to a softball game
and shot it up now I know it's not John
Goodman you know kind of looks like him
is it his brother Ron is it Ron Goodman
Trump hater shoots GOP big GOP big comma
three others both parties stunned by
ballfield horror well yeah obviously did
you need to say that oh it was one of
them not a dog you know what happens you
play softball [ __ ] like this happens
left-wing zeal it whatever that means
sheets Republicans rep for others look
at this foot [ __ ] hilarious
because the daily news is is
left-leaning
says Trump hater they did get that out
that says boat they make sure to say
both parties are that's why they did it
because they're lefties and then over
here the posts whose right wing is like
left-wing zeal it shoots Republican rep
for four others uh why do you guys think
this [ __ ] keeps happening I think it's
the internet you know and I'm telling
you right now if [ __ ] like this keeps
happening if we don't all grow the [ __ ]
up they're going to take the internet
away from us and it probably a smart
thing we should go back to just sort of
living small lives entertaining
ourselves sitting on Stoops during hot
days you know start making music like
your laptop won't work anymore that'll
be like the modern-day washboard I think
we need to just kind of go back to that
you don't even people need to go back to
playing cards playing hearts Fantan all
those old bridge I think that that's
what needs to happen people need to just
kind of walk away from social media and
all of this [ __ ] cuz I think people I
don't know what the deal is stick it
they getting to [ __ ] what kind of a
[ __ ] lunatic I mean what was he
trying to I don't even I don't even I
usually avoid those things but I you
know I'm doing a talk show today so I
got a [ __ ] know what's going on in
the world and being like what's the deal
with this so what's the deal with that
so I figured it'd be the usual some
politician got caught showing his dick
or banging a stripper but now it's just
uh it's just a bunch of UK me [ __ ]
play softball anymore see this is why I
don't read the paper it just makes you
upset you know what [ __ ] this I'm going
for the bread and circus I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna
McGregor first Mayweather you know then
who do I root for I think I got a root
for Mayweather big even though I always
go for the underdog which McGregor has
to be considering you know he has his
Swiss Army knife of [ __ ] he knows how to
do and it's like no the only knife you
can take out is the one Mayweather is
going to use and he's been sharpening
his for the last [ __ ] 30 years 40
years he's been boxing his whole life I
will say this though if McGregor beats
Mayweather I mean is that the end of
boxing did I really just say that is
well I know shaggy on ESPN right now
will this be the end of boxing um it was
already bad when Mayweather and [ __ ]
the Filipino do what the [ __ ] his name
there you know when they should have
fought like thirty years earlier they
finally got around to fighting and then
the the the the Filipino guy who was
also like a congressman at that point
and like a karaoke singer I believe um
he had like a hurt hand when they
finally fought me just took everybody's
[ __ ] money
how many coming white Bentley's are you
gonna buy this guy's you know at some
point people um anyways so I'm here in
New York and I'm I'm I'm sober William
now and I'm I'm enjoying it I really am
I'm getting eight hours [ __ ] sleep
you know I wake up I feel good the sun's
a little brighter you know what it feels
good to have it on me is before you know
I used to be the ad Birds so my new
thing now is I just meet people and I go
to dinner I go to [ __ ] lunch with
them you know so I just met with my one
of my buddies that runs to stand over
there stand comedy club and we went over
to a diner and I'm sitting there and
the thing about LA is there's a bunch of
characters in LA but we're in cars so
you don't get to interact with people in
New York you just walk down the streets
you just get to overhear all this [ __ ]
so I'm sitting there waiting for my
buddy to show up and there's this lady
this lady all the ladies sitting in this
booth and chichi you know you know
little kids wave because it just
learning how to use their arm after a
while you get so old you forget how to
use it again so she's doing like a
little kid wave like it's just like
she's sort of shaking that limb in her
hands just sort of flopping around as if
she has no control over her wrist
anymore that old lady wave right so when
it comes over and says what's the
problem she's like yes there's something
wrong with my coke and I'm thinking okay
they brought Pepsi instead of whatever
coca-cola she goes there's something
wrong with my coke she goes it's it's
not in a can't so you know the way to
let goes I will take care of what will
fix that for you right and she continues
on going I don't know if I forgot to say
it I probably did but it's supposed to
be in a can so he goes to take her full
glass of coke away and as he takes away
she goes I didn't drink out of it like
he was just gonna pass it on to the next
person that orders the coke which was
hilarious
so then I'm sitting there with the buddy
of mine my buddy shows up and as we're
talking we were discussing getting older
and he had some [ __ ] ailment he's
been dealing with and that woman chimes
in says she has the same whatever the
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] older person thing
she chimes in that she has the same
thing and it isn't this type it's that
type and it just it felt like I was on a
Seinfeld episode and then I was just
sitting there laughing cuz she just kept
talking to my buddy and had to turn
around talking to and I was muttering to
him going like I want to see how good
you wrap it up skills are how you gonna
get out of this one he turned back
laughs and going I don't who do we have
to change the subject because she kept
China minute do you have to talk quieter
it's can she hear us right now
um Beryl I thought it was an LA guy I've
just been coming back to New York too
much lately and I'm starting to feel
like I want to live back here again
which is scare me because I have so many
friends
and a whole life out in LA but I mean
I'm doing emphasis finally so I can't
come back but I never thought I'd I
thought I was a lifer out in LA but I'm
coming back here and I'm kind of liking
it so this is the exact same feeling I
used to have when I would go out to LA
from New York after I swore I would
never live out in LA again but then I'm
also thinking like Bill is this just how
you're wired where after a while you
just get tired of a [ __ ] place and
then you want to I don't know Laura I
was born a random man oh by the way
arrested piece Greg Allman Jesus Christ
end of an era the amount of [ __ ]
people dying by the way it's just scare
me because it's just it's kids it used
to be like people that when I was a
little kid I would watch their [ __ ] and
they were already old you know
when the Bob Hope's the Bing Crosby's
the D Martin's the Sammy Davis jr. is
the Frank Sinatra's all of them you know
all of them roof started passing away
but they were old
Telly Savalas you know Lee Marvin
Charles Bronson all of those guys Paul
Newman Steve McQueen all of them Yul
Brenner Jesus Christ till we get it they
were all [ __ ] way before my time a
lot of them are first-generation or they
came over you know like I mean Bronson
came over from Poland he worked in like
coal mines and [ __ ] and but now it's
catching up to where the [ __ ] I am
you know Batman died Davy Jones died
from one of the Monkees right he died
all right Greg Allman died
George Michael it's it's kids creeping
up right it's starting to creep up to
like now these are like people who were
born uh born in the 40s 50s a couple
people around 1960 I was born in 68 and
say hey hey hey hey
[ __ ] pump the brakes here now this is
classic me right
I can still somehow make somebody else's
death about myself isn't that nice all
right so listen this [ __ ] I went into
[ __ ] guitar
santé for like the first time in years I
never go in there but my wife was around
the corner you know taking my lovely
daughter to some doctor's appointment
you know whenever she goes over there
she my daughter cries and stuff I don't
like it I don't like it I know she comes
out better I know the doctors amazing I
don't like going over there you know you
know I just don't you know you thought
I'd get shots and [ __ ] or whatever by
the way we did the total immune thing
and my daughter's fine by the way
we did all of that [ __ ] thank God cuz
everyone [ __ ] was scaring the [ __ ]
out of he like don't don't [ __ ] get
them vaccinated for the mumps that's
gonna cause this it's gonna cause that
and what I finally did was I realized
everybody telling me that none of them
were wearing lab coats and none of them
had medical degrees framed in pictures
behind me and I said I'm gonna roll the
dice with the person that went to school
for this [ __ ] and we did and she's fine
she's totally alert smiles and all that
type of [ __ ] there was nothing bad
happened thank [ __ ] christ but i
don't like to be there when that [ __ ]
goes down so I just said listen I'm
gonna [ __ ] I'll be around the corner
I'm gonna go buy some drum sticks blah
blah blah blah so I walk into guitars
Dada
and I'm there right as it's ten minutes
before it opens it finally opens and I
go upstairs to their drum department you
know because they always do is banish
drums to the back of the music they
always they go [ __ ] yourself right
guitar is the hot chick you know it's
sorta used to be now I'm finding the
electronics all this dead whole
generation like DJ music and all that
[ __ ] is like if that's becoming coming
up more to the front of the store or
becoming a larger surface area of the
store which is another thing making me
feel old other than all these people
that you know where I remembered like
they were young that's what I'm just
trying to say they were like young when
I was young they were like in their 20s
and [ __ ] and now they've lived a full
life and are dead and my kind of [ __ ]
does that happen it's like well bill
you're 49 in 20 years you can be 69
you'd be pushing 70 that's how fast it
[ __ ] goes so um I didn't want to [ __ ]
my point was Jesus Christ am I gonna die
in this week um what's they sayin oh
yeah so I go over to the [ __ ] guitar
Sara and I walk in so I go upstairs to
buy some drumsticks and I'm there so
[ __ ] early there's like nobody there
so I walk up and I grab my drumsticks
that I always get you know get it five B
right and I [ __ ] mom triathlete
chronic drunk kids you know what I mean
they got that sick ass rollin one that
has like literally like a regular kusik
looking bass drum it's [ __ ] around on
that thing that thing's amazing oh my
god if you want to ever feel like you're
ready to play a [ __ ] arena sit down
and one of those [ __ ] rolling kits
and this is not free advertising I'm
just calling a spade a spade they're
[ __ ] unbelievable so um anyways I'm
looking around I sit behind this one kid
I hit go to hit the bass drum and they
got this head on it that looks like a
regular head and it barely makes any
noise I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
what is this technology I didn't know
this existed and then I was looking they
had the little Questlove breakbeat kit
and then they had another one
like an upgraded version of that which
was the the sonar kit and I was like oh
[ __ ] look at these little hashtags and
then they got these heads that make no
[ __ ] noise right what the [ __ ] so I I
just I don't know I just started looking
and I'm like Father's Day Father's Day
is coming up this weekend how about
happy Father's Day to me cuz I got one
of those at my garage I got this DW like
those practice pad kits and those things
[ __ ] suck you can't get through a
song without something falling off they
just suck yeah I [ __ ] hate the thing
all right I want to get rid of it so I'm
sitting there going alright I ordered a
drum kit and I have a studio space ready
to go
but I didn't realize I thought I could
just go down and get the drum kit but
the color I wanted I had to order it
it's not gonna be here for [ __ ] two
months so now what do I do
what do I do in the meantime then
suddenly I get this idea Kalai know I'm
gonna buy one of these little [ __ ]
martini kits here alright I'll keep the
regular heads on and I'll just play in
the studio space on the small kit and
then when my real kit comes I'll just
get rid of the dw1 in my garage and put
the silent heads on it I could just
practice on that when I don't have time
to drive order the [ __ ] little studio
space this is perfect so then I was like
what do i do what do i get the ludwig by
american quest love or the sonar kit
phil rudd ac/dc Steve Smith
right Benny Graham all these monsters
play on these [ __ ] things and I
actually ended up going with the sonar
kit bass drum was a little bit deeper
the floor time wasn't a 13 it was a 14
and it was a badass little bebop kind of
kit and I've gone off the [ __ ] rails
listening to jazz drummers I never
understood it and now with my great drum
teacher and everything I'm starting to
understand it to the point if I sell you
the text messaging that I had the drum
nerd text messaging that I had with my
my drum teacher Oh before I say that by
the way what is so amazing about getting
rid of that John Bonham setup that I had
is now the whole world of what the [ __ ]
do I want to play has opened up
and I don't have any drum kit already
taking up space that was you know
somebody else loved and I loved them so
now I'm going to try to step into their
shoes and it never [ __ ] works that is
completely gone and now I'm just looking
at all these different drum setups going
and [ __ ] like a little bit of that
with a little bit of this it's unreal so
I buy the thing and you know I'm
supposed to walk back over to the
doctor's office with a pair of
drumsticks and you know get back in the
car with my lovely wife my beautiful
daughter but now I bought a little drum
kit so I got this giant box so I just
ended up going all right [ __ ] this I got
to take a picture of the box I just
stood in the back garage they got a
parking lot behind the place I was just
like yeah I kind of bought something I
just took a picture of the box with the
so not kit and I just wrote happy
Father's Day to me he is cool as [ __ ]
she just wrote oh Jesus she's so [ __ ]
cool she doesn't give a [ __ ] right um so
she pulled up and then I opened up I'm
Mike right we got the [ __ ] little
hatchback [ __ ] thing here and I open
it up on the goddamn strollers in there
so I had a move [ __ ] around and do all
this [ __ ] stuff and I gotta tell you
I cannot [ __ ] wait I'm moving into my
little studio thing tomorrow and I
cannot [ __ ] wait and as I mention
I've gone off the rails listen these
jazz drummers and I am now convinced
that Tony Williams is the greatest
drummer of all time and it's not even
[ __ ] close I don't want to start a
debate I know I just did the [ __ ] guy
is unbelievable and I never understood
what he was doing the other than that he
was playing 90 million miles an hour on
his ride cymbal so I was listen to this
album Miles Davis miles miles and
there's a song on there called
footprints it's one of those things that
when I was younger meaning like 46 or 47
boys started taking lessons it would
have just sounded like five guys playing
five different songs
and then that Tony Williams was doing
this Keith Moon [ __ ] underneath it where
he was just soloing or whatever and I
was when I first was listening to it I
only think I could kind of that was
consistent was the bass line it was this
bass line going gaga I got that and I
was just counting that I'm going okay it
since six it's in six and it's and I
don't know what Tony's doing and it's
she's playing 90 million miles an hour
but what's amazing about the song is in
the middle of it
Tony slows down and it's almost like
he's like okay stupid it's in four
alright and here's where it is here's
where b2 is and here's where beat four
is and then after then he only does that
for a couple bars and he speeds up again
looks like a drum class and it's like oh
my god this guy's playing eighth notes
okay
against what this guy's playing that
sounds like it's in six but it's really
just almost like three against four I
notice his nerdy drum ship but there's
got to be a drummer out there that
understands it and then he's doing that
metric modulation thing which there
wasn't even a [ __ ] name for what he
was doing to describe it with then as
he's playing eighth notes that the
eighth notes then it he implies that
that each one of those hi-hat hits is
the two and four and plays the Jazz that
dinged alien ganging against that and
then the E and the tough become the the
[ __ ] one in the three and he's
playing that underneath all of this [ __ ]
so the rest of the band I guess is sort
of playing in an implied six while he's
playing for underneath the doing this
metric modulation to the four what
[ __ ] blows my mind is that he's
playing at that [ __ ] level and it
roughly the same year I was joking with
my teachers that that song by the
Archies sugar came out and was like a
number one hit he's doing that and you
know they sell like 190th of the [ __ ]
albums that a song a sugar boo boo boo
boo boo boo ah
honey dudududududu you know I heard a
story about that song that there's a
keyboard solo which I mean I don't know
[ __ ] about music I was considered a
hacky SOLAS when you take the soul when
you take a solo and all you do is just
play the the melody of the song so that
was basically what the studio musician
on keys was instructed to do so he's
reading the sheet music and he was
playing the solo to that song and
evidently he started laughing when he
was playing it because it sounded like
like some five-year-old [ __ ] but of
course that sells a zillion albums which
brings me back to the Golden State
Warriors Jesus I'm going a long way
where people going yeah this is bad for
basketball why is it getting such high
ratings I'll tell you why because the
Archies out to sell Miles Davis there
you go go [ __ ] yourself I'm done talking
about the NBA so anyways I got a little
sonar kit
I'm so [ __ ] excited to play it I
can't wait I'm not gonna have any time I
won't have any [ __ ] time to do it but
every once in a while old daddy daycare
you know my little princess that's why I
call him my little princess you know she
kept you know babies have those little
cute little fat hands every morning I
wake up I put my little index finger and
in her hand you know she they always
squeeze it and then I bring guys oh good
morning princess and I kiss a little
little fat baby hand you know and you
wouldn't think that within 20 minutes of
that I could get my car and have road
rage but I do you would think at some
point I could be like you know what you
know it doesn't get any better than that
but you know it you know I end up having
these [ __ ] problems can it ever just
sorry just to deal with the recording
here I'm on the road I'm on the road
here headed set it down here so I can
type in my [ __ ] password here um but
yes I am on a a Tony Williams like I
disappeared down the rat hole just it's
it's over
I am completely after all of these years
always loving him but not yet you know I
saw him live and I had no idea what the
[ __ ] he was doing I just knew he was one
of the greats
and I went to go see him and he had you
know he had the yellow Gretsch kit I
mean this was we died 97 I probably saw
him in like 92 93 91 somewhere in Boston
and uh I mean I was in a room bang they
couldn't be more than like a hundred
people there 80 hundred people who jazz
place and I told you this before and
during the break I could I walked up and
I I just was looking at his whole setup
you know we had the black dot heads the
big flick you know 15-inch high hats and
[ __ ] I saw everybody I told you I told
you guys this before I saw Louie Bellson
he just stood there next to his kit you
went up and shook his hand it was nuts
it's [ __ ] nuts by the way I did an
episode of Jay Leno's show his car show
which I don't know if Jay Leno's Garage
I've always been a fan of the website
but I did an episode of it I don't know
when it's going to be coming out but I
don't know if this is gonna make the cut
of you know the final episode of it but
it was weird I was going to be doing his
show and I was reading all this Tony
Williams Miles Davis [ __ ]
and I learned about this jazz club in
Peabody Massachusetts that's no longer
there it was called Lenny's on the
Turnpike it was this little
hole-in-the-wall
and all these guys used to play there
and so then I'd be I don't know I was
read about miles and it said he had a
gig there then I was like Peabody
Massachusetts Jesus Christ I know where
that is so then I started reading about
the jazz club that's what it was and
then I found out that Jay Leno used to
open for the G you know I used to play
there so then the holy [ __ ] I'm working
with him in a week I got to ask him so I
asked him about it he talked about
[ __ ] opening for Miles Davis at
Lenny's on the Turnpike I said holy [ __ ]
what was it like to meet that guy goes
you know it goes he was kind of distant
and I go really and he was kind of you
know
I mean the guide obviously had a
reputation for being a little bit Moody
but he was also he said this is what he
said he goes dude you got to understand
this was it was Boston in the early 70s
as bad as Boston is now it was like a
thousand times even more racist back
then and he was a black guy driving
around on a Ferrari used to get pulled
over like every five feet so he said Jay
was saying that you know when basically
by the time he met Jay he kind of had
his fill of white people so anyways um
let me read something advertising here
this week if anybody else knows any like
cool [ __ ] from that [ __ ] era for me
to listen to I mean it just fascinates
me how like jazz was like the mainstream
and then blues an R&B and then you know
white people turn it into rock and roll
or whatever that that ended up taking
over and it's just like yeah what was
gonna because the direction if jazz just
kept growing and growing growing to the
point that [ __ ] that I was just
explaining to you guys it took me 30
years to understand what the [ __ ] was
going on
just as a regular person you're gonna
lose the mainstream at that point but
you got to give it up to those guys for
having the balls to just say yeah well
[ __ ] it this is the direction we're
going and they have to be like the level
that they were playing they had to know
that half the [ __ ] audience had no
idea what was going on or you just play
into a whole crowd full of musicians
right I know I'm in way over my head who
the [ __ ] am I Who am I I just I'm just a
community does a [ __ ] podcast here
all right let's uh Jesus we got a couple
of reads here um all right frame bridge
everybody Mother's Day is right around
the corner you got to be [ __ ] kidding
me
this is how low on the totem pole men
are that they are they're already
advertising Mother's Day too round the
corner it's [ __ ] 11 months away I'm
[ __ ] with you you know obviously what
they did they forgot to put Father's Day
in there who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] dad go
get
get him a belt give him something else
to beat you with get us some strong
cologne so you know he's coming down the
hall you get a chance to [ __ ] jump
out the window
all right Mother's Day is right around
the corner and frame Father's Day is
right around the corner god damn it
and Mother's Day makes it so easy to
give a thoughtful gift that will last
for years order in minutes without ever
leaving the house and they'll ship your
custom gifts straight to your mom's door
with the personalized gift oh this is
[ __ ] hilarious your dad's door is
this the right [ __ ] does your dad want a
picture go to frame bridge com2 I would
if my daughter got a frame picture the
two of us oh god that melt my heart I
would like that frame picture so much I
would try to figure out how to stick it
my wallet with the frame go to frame
bridge calm choose your frame or let
their designers help you choose upload
your photo from your computer or
directly from Instagram preflu your
preview your photo online in the frame
you choose can upload your photo or art
no worries you can mail it for free
instead of the hundreds you pay at a
framing store their prices start at $39
all shipping is free plus my listeners
my listeners will get 50 15% off their
first order frame bridge comm when they
order using my code BER frame bridge
uses premium real wood moldings
acid-free mat board yeah you know all
this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] great don't get
stuck searching for a last minute gift
order for Father's Day
delivery go to frame bridge calm and use
the promo code bar you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order just
go to frame bridge comp promo Cooper
frame which frame bridge com promo code
Burt yeah just you guys went to a game
together that's a part that's a great
dad gift you know what I mean
unless your dad doesn't like sports and
I don't know what you guys both looking
through a [ __ ] with us
I don't know it's called not a
magnifying glass what's the thing a
microscope
whatever you smart people do all right
zip zip
[Music]
Crudup are you hiring well are you do
you know where to post your job to find
the best candidates you [ __ ] dope
talk about the challenges of finding
great town Jesus you know you can shake
a stick at a dope walking down the
street but can you find a talented one
it's really difficult you got to find
that really great talented person to be
successful in business is that good
how zip recruiter is different oh my god
they're they're way different than
button recruiter with zip recruiter you
could post your job to 100 job sites 100
plus job sites with just one click then
they're powerful technology efficiency
matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else that's why is it
[Music]
it's different unlike other job sites
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them in
fact over 80% of jobs posted on zip look
at a qualified candidate in just 24
hours no juggling emails or calls to
your office office simply screen rate
and manage candidates all in one place
with zip recruiters easy-to-use
dashboard call to action find out today
why zip has been used by businesses of
all so I'm running out of ways to say
these people sizes to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now my listeners can
post jobs on zip recruiter for free
that's right for free just go to zip
recruit accom / / that zip recruiter com
/ / one more time for free go to zip
[Music]
we're dot-com cyber all right that's it
I don't say broker anymore I just yell
alright LegalZoom last one in order to
successfully run your own business
attention to detail is so critical one
contract slip-up or legal
misunderstanding can really set you back
what do you mean were broke fortunately
there's legal zone you may already know
that over half a million over a million
sorry Americans have used Legal Zoom to
stat their own business but LegalZoom
services go well beyond business
formation they'll help you hide a body
they built a nationwide network of
independent attorneys who can provide
legal answers to the day-to-day
questions you have about your business
because let's face it
things like trademarks employ employment
laws and lease agreements can get pretty
complicated it's such a nice way so
let's face it you're [ __ ] dope you
want to deal with this you know what I
am and I'm proud of it so don't waste
your valuable time trying to wrap your
head around all the fine print that's
true all successful people you know what
they do they delegate they delegate they
delegate I'm not good at this [ __ ] hey
you Myron with the glasses you're good
with numbers aren't you
course you are here's a pencil figure
this [ __ ] up so don't waste your
valuable time trying to wrap your head
around all the fine print use legalism
for that so you can focus on growing
your business instead you'll get the
legal help you need without being billed
by the hours since Legal Zoom isn't a
law firm go to legalzoom.com today and
be sure to enter code burr in the
referral box for special savings only at
legalzoom.com all right mercifully my
reading out loud is over you know last
week I might be somehow doing an hour
I'm having such a good [ __ ] time here
all right well I got to read this thing
and then I'm out of here
all right last week our Monday I should
say I read this we had the heading to an
email question and we did not have the
email and Ruth emili´s apologizes
profusely and I had to stop him from
committing Harry Carey all right lady
needing advice don't want to go to mails
friend's wedding
hey Bill I really enjoy the advice
portion of your podcast and could use an
objective opinion I am a lady and have a
male friend that I've been friends with
since I was 10 years old I'm now 29 you
know what guys I got to apologize
something I have this great bit I can't
wait to try out tomorrow night and I
literally was thinking about the joke I
wanted to do and how far I was going to
take it while I read all of that so I
have no idea what's going on this email
if just please forgive me as I reread
this uh I am a lady and have a male
friend that I've been friends with what
he just said you were friends I have a
male friend that had been enemies with I
have a male friend that I've been
friends with since I was 10 years old
I'm 29 now okay so you've been friends
with this guy for 19 years now geez did
he finger bring you panic in the seventh
grade my friend is with this girl that
I've never warmed up to she's a bit now
wait a minute did you always think he
was going to ask you is that what it is
maybe they're not built why just read
the [ __ ] thing she's a bit
condescending phony and I just don't
like her he's he's in his early 30s
she's 25 so she's got you on the old
odometer there and they both currently
live with his mom who also happens to be
a good friend of mine they have crappy
jobs don't pay his mom rent or
contribute much but instead they're
putting money back to have a wedding by
the end of the year I love my friend but
he's always been a bit immature when it
comes to money responsibilities why are
you still hanging out with these people
these people sound like [ __ ] losers
walk away be thankful you didn't hit
your wagon to this [ __ ] I can tell you
right now if you were with this guy and
you were living in his mom's house you
would not be friends with his mom
anymore you'd be like I got to get the
[ __ ] out of here anyways they're not
they're immature when it comes to money
responsibility or what it takes to be an
adult he still depends on his mom a lot
he's 32 this is pathetic
I don't hear a dad in this scenario here
we did he not have a dad he didn't learn
to be am uh be a man I should say law
when my grandmother recently died I was
devastated he asked me for my my address
I thought I would get a sympathy card
but instead I got a save the date card
oh my god that's sad and [ __ ]
hilarious
it pisses me off that he's a bit of a
selfish prick in his own world and also
a dumbass for being in such a rush to
get married when neither one of them has
their [ __ ] together it's difficult for
me to be supportive before you assume
I'm secretly in love with him which I
did I'm sorry our friendship has been
nothing but platonic and I recently got
married myself I'm sorry but this whole
thing read like When Harry Met Sally
except Harry never moved out I don't
want to go I don't want to go to their
wedding my question is do you think I
should put my [ __ ] aside and try to be
supportive of my friend since he's happy
I feel as though our friendship has
shifted a ton since he's been with this
girl and it's no longer easy talking to
him this is what you do you go to the
wedding and then you just gradually back
away you've outgrown these people okay
that's it you're married you have your
own [ __ ] life if he wants to live at
home with his mother with his new wife
whatever the [ __ ] it is is going to do
you just go there and just have a nice
smile on your face just being happy that
you're not on the other side of the I do
okay
I'm still not a hundred percent buying
the fact that you don't have some sort
of feelings for this kid who's now still
acting like a kid in his 30s you're 29
he's 32 he was three years older you
probably said this is perfect then you
envisioned him wearing a suit and coming
home Britain like Hugh Beaumont at the
beginning of Leave It to Beaver with a
higher end [ __ ] GM product Oldsmobile
possibly a Buick who knows
I don't know but this is what I would do
you got to let it go it wasn't meant to
be you can pay and even if you don't
have romantic feelings for this person
all right if you don't have feelings for
this [ __ ] person I can already tell
you the fact that it's so driving you
nuts that you had to write into some
dope like me doing a podcast I don't
know the way the way this is all written
I think you wear your feelings on your
sleeve and they going to know what's up
I would go there you know smile away
that's it and then I would not torture
your husband on the way home or the
whole night critiquing them about how
[ __ ] stupid it is because I can tell
you this right now your husband doesn't
want to [ __ ] go so what you should go
you should do is you should go there and
you should have a great [ __ ] time
with your husband and you should thank
him for not being a [ __ ] loser that
lives at home with his mom there you go
all right and then go to frame bridge
take a picture you tits and give it to
them on Sunday that's the podcast
everybody god bless all you god bless
america uh that's it get off the
internet go sit on the stoop and go make
some music with your friends stop taking
life so [ __ ] seriously stay away from
credit cards stay away from the meth if
your doctor prescribes any painkillers
and has any opiates in it do not take
him tough it out just watch there would
be blood did she sit down the counter
her toughing it out [ __ ] guy dragged
himself out of the [ __ ] Wiley coyote
mind with a broken leg to go in town
just to get a [ __ ] gold nickel
alright you can do it alright that's the
podcast have a great weekend you [ __ ]
and I'll talk to you on Monday
I overrated relationships I do I'd
really want to read this one with you
he's here
can you come near the microphone abhi a
frigging professional when this
unprofessional show why are you wearing
moccasins they're my slipper they're
moccasins hi-yah
you get a little Indian blood in you WI
- you do I have like one let me do
sixteen what do you get Blackfeet yeah
you get it
nothing I get nothing on that that was
stupid
you know what what go [ __ ] yourself here
we go uh relationships so uh sure they
can be good but are they ever great
every married guy I know reminisce is
about his days as a single man married
guys worn single guys not to get into
relationships they warn guys with
girlfriends - never under any
circumstances get married this is all
true when you're single you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want whatever you
want without first I get this closer
without first filtering your decisions
through the desires of a chick who
probably doesn't even know what she
wants most of the time and is motivated
by the worldview of Sex in the City
wow this person sounds like a real prize
yeah but this is true though this isn't
all women a lot of women of [ __ ]
idiots just like guys when you say most
guys are [ __ ] idiots
I would actually and aren't most women
aren't most people [ __ ] idiots listen
we're all rape Abul but when we're
talking all I know is that no one is
unreadable okay okay and I am as exotic
as a grilled cheese sandwich I think
that might be an instant classic um
there wasnt even tomato in that sandwich
was there um even when the chicks get uh
what they think they want they you
they're usually still miserable that's
how stupid most of them are all right
now yeah now he stinks key this is in my
school he's in my quad I like this guy
you're never going to make them happy so
why even try uh not being constrained by
a relationship is one of the greatest
things of all time it's a man's world uh
women need more women need men more than
men need women most men can thrive alone
most women can't he's young you can tell
he's young he hasn't he hasn't liked
women is still looking at him oh yes and
he's learning I was this guy then you
realize at some point you're old and
women don't care anymore so you got to
grab one on just hang on to a drag
down with you um most women can't ask
any honest bisexual girl and she'll like
you tell you that she wants to end up
with a man Jesus this guy just keeps
every time I think he's gone as far as
he's going to go he keeps going I love
him I enjoy being single unless you're a
total [ __ ] failure of a man you
almost always be able to get a
girlfriend if you really want one
realize yeah if you're past a certain
age duty there's a certain amount of
money you have to be making before that
to continue to happen and this is
there's a [ __ ] sadness to that life
that I can't even begin to describe
realize what a blessing your freedom is
and never allowed desperation to put you
in Chains he's making some good points
here he definitely has some issues with
women some uh he's buddies there's a lot
of truth in that Nia they're all enjoy
dying alone [ __ ] hey hey hey well
listen what this is what basically what
you just said was that you're a dumb
girl because that's what he was
attacking what do you mean this is your
work it's your world we were almost out
without an argument but why am i dumb
because he's attacking women whose
worldview comes from Sex in the City
okay so somehow you got offended by that
first of all he's not just attacking
women whose worldview is sex missing
he's oh I think he is he's attacking all
women look at oh I know he was just
meeting some women he was just being
silly just being silly no oh you're
right you're right look you know like
you now his mother never hugged him he's
got issues he that's not our fault
what don't drag me into this I relate to
this guy I'm saying are as women I'm
speaking as women why do you just speak
for yourself you [ __ ] delusional
jackass who elected you you did I'm
sitting here aren't I
well you know I didn't say to represent
all women's I'm not representing all
women's but I think I can say with with
with underwear is clarity that most
smart women who see this would be like
go [ __ ] yourself you douche all right
well uh can I just make a comment about
the whole marriage versus unmarried
thing the grass is always greener on the
other side single people who are alone
look at couples and I get a little
twinge of like oh that's nice I wish I
had somebody to come home to at night
that has my back no matter
what that's what you're missing you
short-sighted [ __ ] is that you've got
somebody there with you who's going to
take this review who's going to love you
and and protect you and have your back
it's not just about like being with
someone just to be with someone we got
it
listen how you will do in the way that I
want to cuz you're being mean this
podcast this podcast this guys crying
out for help oh whatever
fine go on this podcast is not about
being mean and taking shots of people
who can't defend themselves that's
exactly what it was
took you long enough to figure that out
uh all right no but this this there's a
great truth in what he's saying here is
a lot of people just jump in
relationship jump in relationship jump a
relationship and it's like relationships
are [ __ ] difficult yes okay so you
better pick the right person or you're
gonna be [ __ ] miserable so you are
better off to be single and lonely
rather than just being in some [ __ ] to
just be in some [ __ ] so you got somebody
to [ __ ] make brownies with that's
what he was trying to say yeah alright
that he ended up saying that most chicks
are going to be miserable anyway and
they all have the stupid worldview
that's true
most women are going to be miserable and
they're never gonna be [ __ ] happy ok
basing this on you know something you
guys always say a good man is hard to
find that works both [ __ ] ways I
understand well then that this is what
both wealth is mother [ __ ] hasn't
found the one yet so he's going he's
going he's dating a bunch of lashing out
at everybody because he can't seem to
figure out how to make a relationship
work and he can't find the value in the
relationship also automatically it's not
valuable first of all the odd person
lashing out is you right now you've
completely lost your temper is a guy
here he writes in he's looking for a
little bit of goddamn guidance he wants
some advice he got it he's [ __ ]
hilarious
um underrated over 800 for this week
overrated [ __ ] voicemails leaving
them is the most awkward thing I've
always said that I'm terrible at leaving
them but whenever I say that everyone
else whenever I say that everyone else
always says it too so I'm putting my
foot down on the issue and calling it
right now leaving a message for someone
on the phone sucks
there's no way to start your message
normally without sounding like a douche
and then five minutes later you realize
you've been trailing on and on while
saying um too many times making you want
to kill yourself ending with the
inevitable okay thanks bye reminding
them that you still a douche [ __ ]
awful dude this is something that's
really like an epidemic in this young
generation is everybody just feeling
awkward and feeling like a douche I
don't know what happened to you guys I
think this last generation of fathers
they flipped like I'm not going to beat
the [ __ ] out of my kid not hug them and
never tell them that I that I that I
love them you know I'm gonna do all of
that [ __ ] and you end up with these
people who can't even [ __ ] leave
voicemails what is so awkward you know I
I you know what I have a hard time
getting off the phone I forget I forget
what I used to say but I don't feel
awkward but I just feel like an idiot I
guess so I guess I kind of relate I just
go I that's it I'm out of here I will
say that believing a message I like
leaving messages I sing on peoples
voicemails you know whenever I call up
[ __ ] Bobby Bobby Kelly or [ __ ]
Joey roses I call him up and I'll just
immediately I'll just whatever comes my
mind I'll just start singing who's the
[ __ ] that I love the most
who's that [ __ ] who eats the toast
it's Joey he's such a big [ __ ] DeRosa
what's going on it's bill give me a call
back you [ __ ]
click that's it why don't you try
singing you do it for anybody
hey mom what's up you sweet thanks for
having me 40 years ago I sent you some
flowers you didn't call me
do you like my siblings better than me
click right why don't you do that try
that sir try singing first alright
underrated overrated underrated sitting
down to pee if you're a guy uh is it
that how old are you is it that hard to
stand up what is wrong with this [ __ ]
generation of guys you know sitting down
to pee it's actually easier and you
don't get varicose veins from all those
years and Stan there's nothing better
than just pulling out your dick and just
[ __ ] peeing all over everything
you know you [ __ ] shooting the toilet
paper around it's [ __ ] good time
anyways
says the guy who drives a [ __ ] hybrid
anyways there are many benefits to being
a guy in sitting down to pee such as not
having to hear your chick complain about
peeing on the seat even though it's on
the [ __ ] top of the bowl and it's not
actually the seat yep
here's a guy PC he's literally sitting
down to pee so his girlfriend will stop
yelling at him ok I don't know what
happened people a hundred years ago we
could hit him with mop handles and I
don't know what happened they got
organized and we didn't and now we're
sitting down to pee just so they'll stop
yelling at us alright number two if you
like me if you're like me and you wake
up to pee at night you don't have to
[ __ ] with your eyes and turn on the
bathroom lights to aim till you're
taking all the fun out of it that's how
you train your ear alright that sounds
like the back of the bowl where's the
water that's the floor there it is one
small step um number three not bending
down to lift up the seat out you know
what dude you're a [ __ ] pansy
not bending down to clean off to see
less bending in general why don't you
just bend over and suck your own dick as
you sit on the bull you [ __ ] douche
[ __ ] that guy
peeing sitting down you know what else
sir what else is overrated lifting
weights uh owning a gun chewing tobacco
eating steak what else drinking scotch
smoking cigars fixing your own car what
what else sir what else is [ __ ]
overrated everything that makes being a
guy [ __ ] awesome losing your [ __ ]
because some guy you don't know missed a
field goal that really has no effect on
your life talking [ __ ] is that all
overrated Lee Marvin the thing that
saved you sirs you didn't leave your
name so that that's the only thing that
I can say is I can at least see that
there was sort of some sort of shame in
your email